welcome to this video playing Bobby and
something international master from from
Argentina right Argentina um no name in
that oh ok let's see the two nights
variation I play this night of six line
which is not very well known but it
seems to give black quite a decent game
and that yeah give some different
different flavor to the whole position
than in the typical two nights variation
interesting Queen here sure you can also
go to see seven yeah of course this
position is very yeah it's very similar
to french in a way but I've got to
bishop on g4 cousin and yeah he allowed
this trade I wonder where should put the
bishop I can also play g6 Bishop g7
now move like f6 may be possible but not
quite sure that I want this early
complications back of g6 Bishop
treasonous maybe Queen B 5 and ce4 yeah
BG six is a very slow move I want to
make sure that I have a good colonias
development first p 6 yeah maybe this is
about solidifying the Queen side so that
I have no beacon weakness that he can
attack and now my ideas to go Bishop f a
g6 Bishop g7 after all now I can just
take a five if he plays it I he cannot
go d 51 c for this 94 so okay
I'm just preparing this brute bishop of
eight Bishop g7 let them find something
against this idea
uh-huh well I will still do that the the
e5 pawn is a very very nice subject to
attachment uh-huh this is the way to to
protect it he thinks yeah not without
reason but if i look at this at the end
i have f6 willingly exchange or not okay
we should be five you can take with the
rook that's nonsense of course hmm ok so
let's let's shut this down maybe 97 to
f5 I can interesting
hmm night is seven Bishop g5 here but i
have f 6 but it's probably not a great
idea
hmm quite sure how I should continue I
mean I don't have any protection a
problem but how exactly do I continue
let's not sure yeah he's trying to get
the Queen near the king that's nothing
terribly dangerous but I have a hard
time to make any progress and I'm down
on the clock as usual trying to do
something check you know what maybe i
can get Queens off this wood would be
helpful it would be helpful because well
I have the better structure here my g 7
or just Queenie 7 yeah maybe just 27
that's simple jack is getting to g7 now
that was very stupid play hmm
wow how gotta tend to play it now time
learning from simply better position to
this nonsense Wow and now black is just
in terrible shape Ruby g7 yeah the bad
thing is it is also very easy to play
check
yeah that's probably not even the best
what he did but probably totally enough
you can just take a player up g2 and win
okay curious I think he had much easier
ways to do it would you seven probably
still winning
yeah of course it's lost but I can still
play a couple of moves check black yeah
this was a really terrible game my black
what deck I totally totally
underestimated the gphone I mean around
here um I should absolutely never lose I
mean the whole structure is just
favorable for black and losing is really
really a terrible result I mean just for
argument's sake if I play something like
we need seven and just stay white is
never doing anything here he has no pawn
break nothing and it's just sitting on
big pawns so long term white is just
worse it's probably not lost or anything
but like losing is simply unthinkable
but I managed it's possible yeah he has
Bishop h5 which are blundered and he
didn't see gave this chick than g4 yeah
and then Queenie 7s just amazingly maybe
I should still take with the pawn
there's also of course a completely
idiotic way we wait to play by black but
yeah well this this is just just
directly losing
yeah just totally totally stupid yeah
but it's not here it's already tricky
it's got h5 coming I don't really have a
totally sectors satisfactory move queen
is seven is stopped early on yeah that
that that that the whole procedure here
was was bad 97's bad really now maybe
just clean seven and stay for a moment
try to improve it's not easy to do but i
have from some time because white really
has says no and no constructive idea
here it can basically just just shuffle
pieces 97 f4 f5 is not bad strategically
speaking but it's just not working
another idea could be something like
that get the Queen all the way over to
h6 if possible exchanging Queens
obviously would be very nice yeah just a
bad game alright thanks for watching